Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna did not  break up here's what really happens fans  thought the couple already called it  quits after some strange social media  posts China posted a cryptic meme on  Sunday suggesting she's single she later  deleted it and Rob wiped his entire  insta slate clean then posted a photo of  cake for his upcoming birthday on march  17 but a source close to Rob tells ET it  was nothing more than a couple fight  wote they got into a fight and made up  simple as that this will happen multiple  times so get ready they're both very  volatile this is going to be a dramatic  relationship that will play out on  social media ramaa but aside from their  public displays of shade our source says  the Kardashians our team China and Rob  look the family is really happy that  they're together the changes rob has  made in his life are so good they  appreciate China for that they're hoping  this last for longer